- [Narrator] We are the paradoxical ape.
Bipedal, naked, large brained,
long the master of fire,
tools, and language,
but still trying to understand ourselves.
Aware that death is inevitable.
Yet filled with optimism.
We grow up slowly.
We hand down knowledge.
We empathize and deceive.
We shape the future
from our shared understanding of the past.
Carta brings together experts
from diverse disciplines
to exchange insights on who
we are and how we got here.
An exploration made possible
by the generosity of humans like you.
(relaxing music)
- Thank you, Tim.
And thank you to Carta for their vision
in sponsoring these wonderful symposia.
I want to start with one picture here.
Which is a picture of what was intended
to inculcate into the
readers of this magazine,
Time Magazine, that DNA did everything
that you would want in a car.
And, unfortunately for this ad, of course,
Volvo was taken over by Ford.
So, there's been a cultural
change since this ad came out.
We don't know yet what
that cultural change
actually will bring about.
It hasn't been long enough.
But the general problem that we face
is how important are the genes
relative to the other things
that go on in the human life.
And what I'm going to do is to
start quite a bit of time ago
with a picture that tells you about
what my colleague, Cavallie-Sforza,
who just died four weeks ago, and I call
the serial founder effect
of people leaving Africa
between 50 and 100,000 years ago.
And what you see here, the
people who are the most variable.
They have the most variation
in terms of colors and genes.
And, when they leave Africa,
a small number of those individuals
approach this area here,
probably the Levant,
and then they diverge into groups that
go to Africa and Asia.
Some go down into the Oceanic area.
And the final group to move
moves across this Bering
Bridge here into the Americas.
And you can see the
pattern of variation here
is much less variable than here.
Now, some economists,
and I'm referring to
these particular ones,
think that there's
something else going on.
And that they claim that the
pattern of human variation
has been associated with
economic development.
And they did it by doing
the following picture.
Which is this infamous paper
by Ashraf and Galor where,
if you look at this graph here,
which is essentially population
density in the year 1500,
which the economists chose.
And this is a pattern of
lack of genetic variation.
So, the people who lack most
of the absent variation,
or the people who are the most
variable, are the Africans.
And the people who are the least variable
are the indigenous Americans.
And they concluded that having
an intermediate amount of variation
was conducive to economic development.
And this is just one population density.
Just one of the silly things that they do.
But the idea behind bringing
this to your attention is that
this is published in
the most eminent economic
journal in America.
In the world, in fact.
And not only is it silly, but it's wrong.
They claim that a one percentage
point decrease in diversity
for the most diverse society
would be associated with a rise
in its population density by 64%.
So, this kind of misuse of numbers.
Not only was it in that paper,
but it also was brought over
into another paper they wrote
about cultural fragmentation.
And it's trying to point out that
genetic diversity actually is
a cause of these social phenomenon.
Not only were they silly,
but they were wrong.
And there were a series of papers
published shortly after
this one came out that
addressed that their population
estimates were wrong.
Their time of getting
agriculture was wrong.
Whether there was
cooperation in the societies
they were looking at was wrong.
And, of course, how much genetic diversity
was related to innovation was wrong, too.
Because fruit flies have
a lot more genetic diversity than humans.
Their innovation is not nearly
as great as far as we know.
(laughter)
So, in the human genome
diversity cell line panel,
which Luca Cavalli-Sforza and I
started to develop in the early 1990s,
we looked at genomic variation
in people from around the world.
52 populations.
And where they're located is
marked with these red X's here.
And those peoples,
we would love to have a lot more
in the human genome diversity cell line.
And people now have,
in their laboratories,
hundreds of populations
from around the world
where the DNA is currently
available for analysis.
Our idea was to have this
panel available in Paris.
And any lab in the world
could just get the DNA
and do their studies.
And this was the first study
that we did on those people.
In that study, these are
indigenous Americans.
These are indigenous Africans.
And these are Europeans.
But the interesting thing about this slide
is how many of these
populations around the world
have ancestry in more than one place.
Including these people who
have ancestry in three places.
And the Uyghurs in China have
ancestry in three places.
And the Hazara in Pakistan and Afghanistan
have ancestry in three
different continents.
So, ancestry is a much better idea
about describing populations than is race.
Now, if we go back to that
silly economics slide,
when you look at the data that
we've produced from that study.
They were using my data.
That's what made me so mad.
(laughter)
And these were the data they were using.
We plotted mean diversity
as a function of distance
from Addis Ababa.
And what you can see here is that
the Africans have the highest diversity
and the indigenous Americans
have the lowest diversity.
And we're gonna ask why.
Well, I showed you why
in that migration trait.
It was a property of
prehistorical migrations
that the African population
was the population
from which everybody else was derived.
They have the most variation.
They've been there the longest.
They've cumulated the most mutations.
And indigenous Americans have been in
this small group that came
across from the Bering Bridge.
That group's only been in
position for 15,000 years.
As opposed to the 100,000 years
before the indigenous Africans left.
Now, to prove that, we looked at the DNA
of peoples around the world to find out
how long the stretches of DNA were
without any variation should be there.
And what we see is that
there are two kinds of reasons
why people lack variation.
One is the historical
phenomenon that I told you about
of small population size.
That these are the
indigenous American people.
And the other one is
a cultural phenomenon.
And these are all the Islamic
populations in our study.
And they have the same
level of homozygosity,
or lack of variation, as
the indigenous Americans.
And the reason is these populations
practice first cousin marriages.
These are highly inbred populations
from Pakistan, Afghanistan,
and the Middle East.
So, the cultural explanation
is the explanation for this part.
And the historical explanation
is the explanation for that part.
That's the demography side.
Now, since that study,
there have been 189 populations studied.
And I'll ask you to focus on this list.
What we see here are the
indigenous Americans.
And what we're looking at here is
having five million nucleotides
without any variation.
And we see mostly that the
populations in the Americas
have a very high rate of homozygosity.
The populations of Islamic extraction
And these populations here
are really interesting.
These are the Jewish populations.
And one of those populations
is particularly interesting.
This one here.
That's a population in
Israel called the Samaritans.
And most of you have
heard of the Samaritans,
'cause there was a good one.
(laughter)
Now, the Samaritans are
an interesting group,
because they don't believe that
they should be separated
from the other Israelites.
They have a very interesting history.
This is the high priest of the Samaritans.
Currently there are about 850 of them.
Half live in the center of Tel Aviv
and half live in a
village in the West Bank.
But, in 1917, there were
150 Samaritans left.
They spoke Aramaic.
And they did not believe
in any of the Bible.
Except the five books of Moses.
The rest of it, the
prophets and the writings,
they didn't care about.
And part of the reason is their history.
This is the Assyrian Empire
between 900 and 607 BC.
And this is the history.
Everybody can read this for themselves.
(laughter)
This is called the Nimrud Prism
in which Emperor Sargon II,
who conquered the
northern kingdom of Israel
in the year 722 BC,
wrote down what he did.
And this is the story.
Now, if you want an easier bit,
you can read the translation here.
He tells that he took out the people,
as was his custom, from
the northern kingdom.
Moved them to what is now Iraq.
And replaced them with people
who he had already conquered.
And this was his pattern.
However, the Samaritans believe that
they descend from people who never left.
That they are the descendants of
the children of Manasseh and Ephraim.
Two of the children of Joseph.
Two sons of Joseph.
They never left.
Now, the Bible actually has
a contradiction about these people.
Because, if you look at the book of Kings,
it says exactly what
the Nimrud Prism says.
That he took.
The kind of Assyria
brought men from Babylon
and these other places
and placed them in the cities of Samaria
instead of the children of Israel.
Unfortunately, the Chronicles
says exactly something else.
Because Hezekiah is the king
of the Solomonic Empire.
And this is in the year 700.
This is after the conquest.
So, if the Israelites had
been taken over and left
and there were none there,
why would he be writing
to Israel and Judah
and the children of Ephraim and Manasseh?
And asking them to come to
Jerusalem to keep the Passover?
So, there's a contradiction there.
And the scholars say,
"Oh, Chronicles is written
a lot longer after."
It goes to about 400 BC.
And the book of Kings is really kosher.
We've got to believe that one.
So, either way, there's
something to explain here.
And so, we tried to explain it.
Being a Samaritan is passed
down along the male line.
Male Samaritans can marry anybody.
And the children is a Samaritan.
There are only four families.
Cohen, Joshua-Marhiv, Danfi, and Tsedaka.
And they are endogamous.
They marry within the line.
So, it's not unexpected that
they have the highest
inbreeding coefficient
of any population in the world.
They're the only population I know of
where a quarter of the mothers and sisters
of color blind men are also color blind.
Because, as you know, color
blindness usually in males.
So, the Samaritans are
really quite interesting.
But, as a consequence of
this cultural phenomenon
of preferring to marry within the line,
within the marriage line,
they have these genetic properties.
Which we can get at by
looking at the Y chromosome.
Because the descending gene
which defines you as a Samaritan
is your Y chromosome.
Because only males can pass
being a Samaritan down.
So, we did that.
We looked at the Y
chromosomes of the Samaritans
and compared them to
all the other populations
of Jewish people in Israel.
And, in addition, to Palestinian
and to Ethiopian Jews
and to Druze and Bedouin.
And, lo and behold, they're
the closest, by far,
to today's Cohens.
And Cohens are the high
priests of the Jewish religion.
So, it turns out that Samaritans
are actually related closer
to the Jewish people.
And they're Israelites.
They must be Israelites to
have this close relationship
on the Y chromosome.
If you study mitochondrial DNA,
it's a totally different story.
Because the women are
coming from everywhere.
They're not from the Samaritans.
So, you won't see anything
like this, which we did.
Which is an interesting phenomena.
So, the culture has
again defined the pattern
of genomic variation.
Why did this happen?
Well, this guy Josephus,
an interesting fellow who was
hated by the Jews of the time,
because he was a turncoat.
He joined the Romans and
became a writer and reporter
for the Romans.
And the Romans who were in Israel
and destroying the Temple.
He particularly attached
himself to Vespasian
who destroyed the Temple in the year 70.
And he writes about a time of history
300 or 400 years before him.
And he mentions Sanballetes,
who is that Persian governor
of Samaria and Judea,
and Manasses, who is the brother
of the high priest in Jerusalem.
Now, he'd have to be a Cohen,
because only Cohens were high priests.
And Josephus says that Sanballetes
gave Manasses his daughter.
And, along with other of the high priests,
they converted to become
essentially Jewish Samaritan.
So, they were Cohens.
So, the male lineage descends,
according to Josephus,
from that line.
So, we don't know whether
there's any truth to this.
This is the only evidence that
I and my religious scholars
have been able to find
to say why the Samaritans
should be related to the Cohens.
The high priests of the Jewish religion.
Now, my final example of
how culture affects genes
concerns the Canadian fur
trade and tuberculosis.
This is a pattern of the global
incidence of tuberculosis.
Right from the United Nations documents.
It hasn't changed much since then.
Maybe gotten a little worse
down here in southern Africa
with the advent of HIV.
This is a story from the famous book
written by Ferguson in 1928 about
how many deaths occurred from TB
in indigenous American
Canadian populations.
And these two peaks,
which tell you over 10%,
maybe 14% of indigenous
Americans in Canada
died in those times.
They died because they
were put into reservations.
And the reservations were
extremely badly designed.
The people were dying like
flies of infectious diseases.
They had no blankets, no ventilation.
So, the question is, if these
people had that problem,
then why is it the case that
so many indigenous Americans
in that part of Canada died?
This lady, who's pictured here
in the canoe of the fur traders
going down this long river here,
this river zone here from Quebec.
We found out that, if
we actually looked at
the DNA of the bacterium that was
in the Canadian indigenous peoples,
it was exactly the same DNA that
was in the people from Quebec.
Those people, the French Canadians,
were in the Northwest Fur Trading Company.
And the French had a different
culture from the British.
The French cohabited with
the indigenous people.
And they passed on their TB bacterium.
The British never homesteaded.
They never passed on anything.
They were hands off the indigenous people.
So, what we see is this culture
of cohabiting with the indigenous people
that the French Canadian fur trappers did
was the reason why that bacterium
passed these 1500 kilometers
into the indigenous people.
So, in conclusion, it's obvious that,
if you look at the cultural context
around these human behaviors
and the variation of the DNA,
you can see that you can't say that
it's the DNA that's
causing these variations.
Thank you.
(applause)
- So, I have something
that predates the stone.
These are palm nuts.
Good afternoon, ladies and gentlemen.
I'm pleased to be here to
speak at this Carta event.
And I thank Doctor White
and Doctor Churchland
for the invitation.
Like you, I'm passionately interested
in the human mind and human behavior.
And my particular interests
are in what humans
share with other species
and how they are different.
Understanding humans as
members of the natural world
is critical to understanding
human origins and our future.
Let's start with how
humans use hand tools.
Now, humans use hand tools like these now.
And how our ancestors used
them in the deep past.
We can see some continuities.
We can use chopper cores, too.
Even though we might not
be able to manufacture
a chopper core like this
one without practice.
What about nonhuman primates?
Jane Goodall gave compelling reports
of wild chimpanzees fishing
for termites with grass stems.
Prompting Louis Leakey's famous quote.
"Now we must redefine tool, redefine man,
or accept chimpanzees as humans."
(laughter)
But the idea that scientists
in the mid-20th century
were unaware of nonhuman primates
naturally using tools is inaccurate.
Darwin, citing a report published
more than 100 years before
Jane Goodall's report,
mentioned wild chimpanzees
cracking nuts with stones
in his book The Descent of Man.
Goodall's discovery should
not have come as a surprise.
Even if earlier reports
of chimpanzees cracking nuts
with stones had been forgotten
Because psychologists had studied
chimpanzees and capuchin monkeys
spontaneously using objects as tools
in captive settings for decades.
Wolfgang Kohler and Yerkes
studied captive apes.
And Heinrich Kluver
studied capuchin monkeys.
Studies with captive
nonhuman primates using tools
have continued since then.
And we've learned much from them.
I'm going to focus, however,
on what we know about
nonhuman primates' behavior
in natural settings.
In keeping with the
situations of human ancestors
and contemporary humans
whose behavior and brains
we're hoping to understand.
I'm going to focus on those species that
have been found to use
hand tools regularly
in their daily lives as humans did and do.
So, what can we learn from
nonhuman primates' use of hand tools
that helps us understand human origins
and our contemporary minds and behavior?
First, we can learn what is shared
and we can deduce what is not shared.
And then we can work to
explain the differences.
So, let's start with the forms of tooling
that we find in nonhuman primates.
And I use the word tooling to mean
using an object as a tool.
Four genera of nonhuman primates
regularly use hand tools.
And, in each genus,
one species has been most
studied in this regard.
And I'm going to focus on those species.
Two species are apes.
Two are monkeys.
Two are Asian.
One African.
One South American.
Thus, they come from across the regions
in which nonhuman primates live.
They most frequently use hand tools
to hammer, puncture, scrape, probe, rake,
and in a few other ways.
In these forms of toolings,
nonhuman primates perform simple actions.
They produce a change in a
substrate or a fixed object
with one object.
A stick or a stone.
Here, a chimpanzee punctures the soil
to get at an underground termite nest.
A macaque hammers an oyster with stone.
And a capuchin monkey is scraping the sand
away from a tuber in the ground.
They use a hand tool to
alter one loose object.
To pound a loose gastropod.
In this case, by a macaque.
Or a chimpanzee or capuchin
monkey cracking nuts.
They generate novel combinations
of actions with objects.
Some of which plausibly could
lead to achieving their goal.
But often they don't.
This young monkey stacked
a nut on a small stone
on a larger piece of stone
and then prepared to strike
it with his third stone.
And that didn't work.
They use simple toolkits.
That is, they use two or more items
in a sequence for different subgoals.
On the left, a chimpanzee
uses a stout branch
to break into a bees nest.
And then, on the right,
she uses a smaller branch
to dip for honey and larvae.
They select and transport materials.
Taken as evidence of planning.
That was a capuchin monkey
transporting a stone
bipedally several meters to an anvil.
Here, we see.
I think I have to click again.
Another monkey.
He's selecting a heavier stone.
Which, in this case, is the smaller one.
He taps and handles both stones
before selecting the heavier
stone to carry to the anvil.
This is Elisabetta Visalberghi
narrating in Italian.
The lighter one, although larger,
was too light to be an affective hammer.
We manufactured the stones
for that experiment.
They modify materials and
manufacture tools by subtraction.
Breaking sticks from branches
and twigs from sticks, for example.
Here, we see a chimpanzee
fishing for termites
using a stem that she
collected from a plant
like those shown on the left.
Which she then modified by
chewing on it to have a brush tip.
The lower right image shows how
the brush tip helps to
collect the termites.
They use skilled movements to achieve
a good mechanical effect with the tool.
By skill, I mean achieving the goal
with minimal effort and
maximal effectiveness.
This capuchin monkey can crack nuts
far more skillfully than I
can using the same stone.
And I can tell you I've tried many times.
(laughter)
He does it in three strikes.
And he was cracking a nut like this.
The monkey weighs three and a half kilos.
This is a big stone.
Or a big nut for monkey that size.
They learn to use stone tools with others
and from artifacts left by others.
In other words, they have
technical traditions.
They learn these skills
over a very lengthy period.
Chimpanzees learn to crack nuts
over about a three year period.
Progressing from actions with one object
to combining objects and then percussing
and finally cracking nuts
when they're about three years old.
Burmese macaques learn to harvest oysters
and crack loose gastropods
in a similar timeframe.
With somewhat different
order of appearance
of the elements compared to chimpanzees.
Bearded capuchins similarly
begin handling objects
soon after birth.
But do not begin to place
an object on a surface
and then work on it with another object
until they're around two years old.
And they begin to crack nuts
some months or even years after that.
All in all, the developmental timelines
are quite similar across these species.
Orangutans may develop their
tool using skills more slowly,
but we really don't have
good ontogenetic data
on this point yet.
These primates, like
humans, forage extractively.
That is they collect food that is
hidden in wood or soil
or protected by tough shells or rinds
or by thorns or irritating latex.
Some way they're defended.
We see, on the right, a
capuchin monkey extracting
a plant underground storage
organ from the soil.
He's not using a tool for that.
He's digging in the sand with his hands.
They use tools to process
abundant, high-quality foods.
Here, we see palm nuts eaten by
capuchin monkeys on the left.
Coula nuts, also called African walnuts,
eaten by chimpanzees in the center.
And a diverse array of
gastropods and marine organisms
cracked by the macaques.
These are all abundant foods.
They're nutritious.
Good, high-quality foods.
They all spend a lot of time on the ground
and forage on the ground.
Except for orangutans.
And this is an interesting point.
And one that Meulman and van
Schaik have commented on.
If you're looking for a book about
tool use in nonhuman primates,
this is actually about not just primates.
But it's called Tool Use in Animals.
Edited by Sanz, Call, and Boesch.
It's a good book if you're
interested in this topic.
The shared features I have mentioned.
And some others that I list here.
Bimanual actions,
complementary bimanual actions,
modulating movements,
hierarchical organization
of action sequence,
preparatory movements
with a tool before use,
and others that I don't
have time to talk about.
These are all things that reveal
shared perceptual, motor,
cognitive, and social foundations
for tooling in primates.
And yet nonhuman primates do not use tools
as shown in these pictures
that are very common actions for humans.
They don't do it spontaneously.
And, to my knowledge, they don't
do it with training either.
Why not?
They don't seem to be limited
by gross sensory or motor characteristics.
Here, we see a drawing of a chimpanzee
delicately and dextrously
handling a plant stem
and holding a rigid stick.
These were drawings taken from video.
Instead, they differ from
humans in more subtle ways.
Humans perceive spatial relations
between objects differently.
For example, from two years of age,
we can align the axes of objects
and surfaces to each other
accurately and easily.
As when you insert a key into a keyhole.
And nonhuman primates do not.
As far as we now know.
Nonhuman primates align points.
They can align align a probe to a hole.
That's a point alignment.
But they don't align axes to each other.
So, here, we see a bar, a cross,
and a kind of tomahawk shape.
And a corresponding cutout in a tray.
And two year old children can
put in the bar and the cross.
And three and four year old children
can manage that tomahawk shape.
And nonhuman primates,
with a lot of effort,
can get the bar in.
And they actually can get them all in,
if you just give them long enough.
But they don't just pick it up, rotate it,
position it, and place it in.
They do it by smearing the
thing around on the surface.
And, eventually, they get it in.
It's a very different strategy.
Nonhuman primates move
one object at a time.
Managing a few degrees of freedom.
Humans manage two objects
concurrently and sometimes more.
As when knitting.
I think knitting is an
underappreciated skill.
(laughter)
In some, humans can coordinate
movements in space more precisely,
especially movements
organized with respect to
the target object or objects,
than nonhuman primates.
Humans can manage a
greater number of relations
between objects concurrently
than nonhuman primates.
Humans also have more
elaborate social cognition.
And this plays out in many ways.
Without teaching and without
intentional scaffolding,
nonhuman primates learn
their technical skills
less efficiently than do humans.
Turning to the question that
Doctors White and Churchland
asked us to address,
how did the use of tools contribute
to the origins of our
species' brains and cognition?
I would say, as a primatologist,
that I want to turn the question around.
I want to know what features
of ancestral hominins
and their ecological and
their social circumstances
set the stage for humans to expand into
a specialized foraging niche
that increasingly relied
on using tools?
My suggestion is that
natural selection for
perceptual and behavioral attributes
associated with extractive foraging,
particularly the perception and management
of spacial relations among objects
and the precise control of the movements
of the body plus object system,
slowly but eventually
enabled ancestral humans
to expand into a
specialized foraging niche
that relied on using tools.
Humans are obligate tool users.
No nonhuman primate is
an obligate tool user.
In other words, I suggest that
the key evolutionary
shifts that got humans
started down this path were
perceptual and action components
associated with handling and
moving objects during foraging.
These shifts enable humans to use tools
far more flexibly than
can nonhuman primates.
Of course, other aspects
of human biology that
are associated with tool
use were coevolving.
Including morphology, social cognition,
attentional control, memory
strategies, and so on.
So, our next speaker is going
to tell us something more
about how these features
played out in human evolution.
I want to take just a few moments,
the remaining time that I have,
to tell you a bit more about
the work that I do in Brazil
and the monkeys that I think
are so interesting to study.
And I do this work collaboratively
with Patricia Izar and
Elisabetta Visalberghi
who are shown in that photo.
These monkeys collect palm nuts.
They take them to anvils
and they use stone hammers
to crack them at those anvils.
You've seen a few clips
of what these monkeys do.
This one shows a female
positioning the nut very carefully
and working on that stone.
And this is completely characteristic.
What she's doing looks.
It's not chaotic or random.
There's actually quite
a bit of method there.
In the end, she arrives at the nut
in a very stable position on the anvil.
And then she whacks it.
Even though it does
sometimes fly off the anvil.
That's just one of the
hazards of the occupation.
(laughter)
Very slow motion.
There's really beauty in that action.
I think these monkeys
are Hercules with a tail.
(laughter)
Capuchins have all the characteristics
we associate with tool use in primates.
They're quite terrestrial.
They use bipedal stance
occasionally on the ground
to look around.
They transport things bipedally.
They're extractive foragers.
They percuss objects during foraging.
Even when they're not using tools.
They're tolerant to
young monkeys near them
while they're foraging.
They're generally social cohesive.
Their habitat has features that
make the monkeys' nut cracking
likely and of use to them.
Nuts and anvil sites are abundant.
The hammer stones are not.
Those are the restricted resources.
The nuts and the larvae
that they often contain
are both preferred and nutritious.
And they're available all year long.
So, it makes a lot of sense,
if you're a capuchin
monkey living in this area,
to crack nuts.
Thank you very much.
(applause)
- I'm very happy to be here today
to talk about a topic that's
very near and dear to my heart.
Which is the role of
technology in human evolution.
In fact, if you go back about 60 years,
it was pretty much a
widespread viewpoint that
technology and toolmaking
was absolutely central
to human evolution.
And, in fact, perhaps
definitive of our species.
But this was graphically
represented in a film in 1968.
2001: A Space Odyssey.
Which depicts this turning point.
A critical turning
point in human evolution
when this Australopithecine,
male, of course,
realizes that he can use a bone as a club.
And then proceeds to
slaughter his rivals with it.
From then, our future was assured.
And, virtually inevitable, in triumph,
he tosses the stone up in the air.
It spins around.
And then, on the way back
down, it, very smoothly,
at least in 1960s cinematography,
turns into a spaceship.
So, you get the picture, right?
But, already, by the time
that this film had come out.
And you saw this quote
in the last presentation.
This vision of Man, the Toolmaker
had started to unravel a bit.
As Louis Leakey famously quipped,
"Now we must redefine man, redefine tool,
or accept chimpanzees as human."
And, in fact, now we know
it's not just the chimpanzees.
It's not even just the primates.
If you're willing to accept
kind of covering yourself
with a coconut as tool use,
it goes into molluscs even using tools.
And, as archeologists, we also know that
the earliest appearance
of flaked stone tools
was not really a
transformative breakthrough
that we thought.
The first stone tools appear
around 3.3 million years.
And then nothing happens.
In fact, the graph should
probably look more like this.
You have a little bit of a
flash or a flash in the pan.
Let me get the laser pointer up here.
At 3.3 million years ago.
Then a whole lot of nothing.
Until about 2.6 where you
have some low intensity
mucking about in tool making.
But it doesn't really take off
until after two million years.
So, maybe early stone tools really
aren't that much of a big deal after all.
But, obviously, I don't believe that.
And, in fact, you could say that
the termite probe here is a tool.
The phone is a tool.
They are the same thing qualitatively.
But, quantitatively,
there's a massive difference in complexity
that we need to explain.
So, take this famous scene
from the Shibuya Crossing in Tokyo.
Arguably, there's not a single
natural thing in sight here.
Even the people, even the bodies,
the human bodies have been transformed
by this long engagement with technology.
The reduction in the size
of our jaws and teeth
and our gut from external
processing of food.
The adaptations to the hand and arm
for dextrous manipulation.
Of course, the very large,
energy hungry brain.
But the other thing to
notice in this picture
is how many people there are.
Despite this really expensive brain,
the very long development,
the heavy investment that children require
that you may be familiar with,
(laughter)
there's more than seven
billion of us on the planet.
Compared to the other apes,
human mothers have the
shortest interbirth interval
and the highest total fertility rate.
Despite having these
really expensive offspring.
So, basically, they should not
be able to afford to do this.
Human women should not be able to afford
this rate of reproduction.
So, how do they do it is
they do receive assistance from others.
This could be fathers.
It could be siblings.
It could be grandparents,
other members of the community
in a strategy that's been called
a human biocultural reproductive strategy.
But, obviously, for
these other individuals
to provide assistance to human mothers,
they have to produce more than
just what they themselves need to survive.
And, throughout the life course,
chimpanzees pretty much
produce what they can consume
and consume what they can produce.
Except for maybe a little bit of nursing
right here at the outset.
It tracks closely.
Now, humans, we have this
long, very expensive childhood
in which we are producing much
less than we're consuming.
But, eventually, we're able
to start producing a surplus.
And the reason for this
is what I call technology.
These culturally inherited,
passed on techniques
for exploiting the environment.
Alright, so, this describes
a human technological niche.
What you've got here is
a powerful biocultural feedback cycle
where technology can increase production,
which provides the resources for sharing.
Which can subsidize long,
expensive development
and population growth.
Which makes it possible to
grow and educate a large brain.
Which makes it possible
to have further technological
innovations and so forth.
Now, as I articulate it there,
this suggests a very
powerful, as I said, feedback.
Or even a runaway feedback curve.
So, maybe we're back to
the guy tossing the bone
in the air after all.
Once it gets started, how do you stop it?
But, in fact, not every
technological innovation
is necessarily gonna be a game changer
that is going to increase your production.
Increase in intelligence may lead
to a greater refinement of tool making
rather than some kind of innovation.
And so, models that take the interaction
between some of these
variables into account,
they can produce this exponential curve.
But they can also produce a
series of steps and plateaus
that's a lot more like what
the archeological record
actually looks like.
So, unfortunately, things are complicated.
Life is complicated.
And we have to turn to the
actual archeological record
and try to figure out what
happened, when, where, and why.
So, why didn't the earliest
stone tools take off?
Why wasn't this a game changer?
So, if you've ever loosened
or tightened a screw
using the knife you happened
to have in your hand
rather than digging
through your tool chest
to get a proper screwdriver
or if you've weighed
the costs and benefits
of updating your operating system,
you know that technology comes
with both costs and benefits.
So, for instance, technology might
increase your rate of return.
But, before you can start employing it,
you may have to gather raw materials.
You may have to actually
produce and maintain the tools.
And, critically, you've got to learn
how to do all of these things
before you can even start
harvesting from the environment.
And, in some circumstances,
you'd be better off
to just start right in
with a simpler technology
rather than wasting all of this time.
I'm going to focus.
Actually, the argument here.
I should make it explicit,
is that this could help to explain
some of the patterning that
we see in the archeological record.
I'm going to focus in
particular on skill learning.
The cost of skill learning,
because this is something
that, evolutionarily,
brain evolution could mitigate
the costs of skill evolution.
Of skill learning.
I'm sorry.
And also changes in our
donation of time and energy
in the form of teaching.
So, sharing our time and
energy to teach others
could alter the costs and benefits
of investment in skill learning.
Alright, so, chimpanzees,
apes, can make stone tools.
But they don't do it in the wild.
And, in fact, it takes
them a really long time
to learn how to do it and
how to make tools that are,
frankly, not very good.
So, it's really no wonder that
they don't bother to do this.
Now, part of the reason.
Doctor Fragaszy talked about some of this.
Part of the reason is probably
has to do with their hands.
So, they have these very long fingers that
make some of the manipulations of stones
that we do for stone
tool making difficult.
But I think that there's more
to it than just the hands.
So, for reference, here
is a skilled modern human
making simple stone flakes.
These pieces, these sharp pieces of rock
that are coming off are
surprisingly effective knives.
Actually, you can use them to butcher
a wide range of animals.
And what's required here is to identify
the appropriate geometry on the stone
to very dextrously
manipulate and support it
with the left hand while delivering
very forceful and accurate
strikes with the right hand.
Now, this is not rocket science.
But it does require some
pretty sophisticated
spatial relationships.
As well as some highly skilled
manual movements and control.
So, I don't think it's just the fingers.
But I think it's also the
brain that's involved here.
That makes this easier for humans
than it is for chimpanzees.
And, in fact, humans have
an expanded neural system,
a dorsal stream, for relating things
like spatial relations, body positions,
object identification,
and kinematics to technological goals.
That I think makes it
easier and less costly
for humans to learn these kinds of skills.
And, in fact, this is exactly.
If you do a functional imaging
of the systems that are activated
during simple stone tool making,
this is the same network of structures
that you see involved there.
So, if we turn to Australopithecines,
with their small brains,
with large jaws and teeth and guts
adapted for digesting
unprocessed kinds of foods.
With hands and arms that
may or may not have been
up to the task.
It's probably the case
that stone tool making
just wasn't really worth it
for them as an investment.
The exception, then,
that proves the rule here
is the Lomekwian stone tool making.
Which actually is produced
using less demanding techniques.
Like indirect percussion against a rock,
a stationary rock like this.
Or bipolar shattering on an anvil.
And you can see that the experimenter here
actually has their fingers bound together
to make this point.
It requires a lot less
demanding manipulation.
So, less investment in skill,
but, perhaps, also,
less payoff in terms of
the effectiveness of the technology.
By 2.5, 2.6 million years ago,
we do have evidence of
more skill intensive,
more dextrous freehand flaking.
Like what we saw in that video.
From the site of Gona in Ethiopia.
Where I work with Doctor Sileshi Semaw.
And you can see some of these tools
are made very finely.
Very small.
Some very delicate flaking
and precise gestures involved there.
And arguably could then be
a more efficient technology
that might have a better payoff.
We don't really know very
much about early Homo
that was around at this time.
Except the teeth maybe
are a little bit smaller.
We could speculate the
brain's also bigger.
But we don't know.
Australopithecine's also around
at the right time and place
to make these tools.
Don't show any obvious
adaptations for tool making.
And the sites on the landscape remain rare
and somewhat ephemeral.
And so, this is maybe sometimes worth it.
And it's only after about
two million years ago
that we see what I'm going to loosely call
habitual tool making.
Habitual tool making.
I think John Shay, who we'll hear from,
has a different definition of habitual.
But I just mean in the sense that
they're doing it much more frequently.
The sites are larger.
They are denser.
They occur across more of the continent.
It persists.
And this is interesting,
because there's a pretty loose.
We like to do these correspondencies
between this shift in the technology
and the appearance of evidence of
larger brain and body size.
And it's pretty rapidly after that,
by 1.8, 1.7 million years ago,
that we see the invention of
an entirely new technology.
That's what we call the Early Acheulean.
Where, for the first time,
tools were being made
to an intentional shape
and posing a point.
These things we call picks and hand axes.
Which are often made by
striking a really large flake
off of a boulder core.
Which requires a whole different technique
and different kind of manual skill.
And seems to go hand in hand
with the appearance of Homo erectus.
In the loose sense with
larger brains and body size.
This then appears to be a
fairly stable adaptation.
With or without hand
ax, hominids are able to
inhabit diverse environments
throughout Eurasia.
Even up to the edge of
the boreal zone here.
And, in places where hand
axes were made consistently,
like throughout this
period, like in East Africa,
there is some evidence of
incremental refinement.
But, overall, things
seem to be pretty stable,
if variable.
Stable but variable for about
a million years or more.
And it's by then about
half a million years ago
we see clear evidence that
we've entered into another
period of abrupt change
indicated by rapid encephalization.
By the expansion into new habitats.
And by the appearance of new
forms of technology, as well.
And one of these that I've
studied in some detail
are Late Acheulean style hand axes,
like this one from Boxgrove in the UK.
And, in contrast to earlier
tools, earlier hand axes,
these are very nicely shaped.
And especially made very flat
and thin in cross section.
And I emphasize that
because that's actually
a very difficult thing
to achieve with a rock
by hitting it with another rock.
You start off with a big nodule.
Irregularly shaped.
And you have to flatten that thing down.
And the only way you're
going to be able to do that
is if you can strike flakes that
travel more than halfway
across the surface of the rock.
And, to enable that kind of fracture,
you really need to be
able to delicately adjust
the angle, the placement, and the bevel
of the edge relative to the midline
in order to ensure that
the flake you strike
is actually going to
to travel some distance
along the core face.
Archeologists call this
striking platform preparation.
And this entire technology
is a very demanding one.
So, in order to find out
a little bit more about
exactly what goes into
learning how to do this,
we recently ran an experiment
training modern people to make
these kinds of stone tools.
About 20 people.
They received close to
100 hours of training.
Each from an expert stone tool
maker, Doctor Nada Khreisheh.
Their products.
And we've collected all
kinds of information
about these people and their behavior.
Their lithic products I'll talk about.
The actual tools they
made have been analyzed
by Doctor Justin Pargenter
in my lab, as well.
He's my current post-doc.
And what we found is a
classic power learning curve.
In which early progress is rapid.
But then it asymptotes off
to pretty much a plateau.
Diminishing returns from practice.
You may be familiar
with this kind of effect
in sports or anything like that.
It's found across a wide
range of different skills.
Things being as they are in life,
although we tried to
control training time,
there was some variability in how often
people were able to make it
into the lab for training sessions.
And we found that not only is it
the total amount of practice
that you've racked up,
but it's actually the density,
the frequency and
intensity of your practice
that helps to determine
individual differences
in the progress of skill learning.
I want to point out here that
this scale is actually a five point scale.
So, the top is not even
being shown on the graph.
Because nobody even got
close to it in 90 hours.
We could extrapolate from
individual learning curves that
people in our study we
expect would have taken
anywhere from 121 hours to over 400 hours
to achieve mastery
comparable to what we see
at Boxgrove in this kind of tool making.
This is a very substantial
investment of time.
Especially considering that
we've given these people everything.
They don't have to gather their tools.
Don't have to make their equipment.
It's all right there for them.
And we're still talking
several hundred hours
of dedicated practice.
And this, to us, begins to suggest that
we may be starting to see
some of the kinds of support
that modern humans provide for
the transmission of
complex technical skills.
Everything ranging from
intentional demonstration,
perhaps explicit teaching.
Certainly social support,
coaching, scaffolding,
and encouragement.
So, the social context.
A very important part of what's evolving
here in the technological niche.
The other thing, of course, is that
learning complex skills does
require complex cognition.
And, during this initial
jump in performance here,
we found that individual differences
in how rapidly you kind
of learn this skill
were related to your performance
on a classic neuropsychological
test of set shifting.
Basically, you have to match
this card to one of these.
You can match either on
shape or color or number.
And your ability to do that.
They keep changing the rules.
Your ability to recognize
when a rule has changed,
it's your set shifting ability.
And, if you temporarily mess with
the part of the brain that controls this
in the right inferior frontal
gyrus with a magnetic pulse,
it slows people down in being able
to put together complex action sequences.
Not coincidentally, this
very same part of the brain
is what we consistently find to be active
in functional imaging studies
of people making stone tools.
It also experiences changes
in white matter conductivity
during training.
In fact, these changes are paralleled
by species differences between
humans and chimpanzees.
And, particularly, it's
the right hemisphere
inferior frontal gyrus.
So, we can say that evolutionary changes
to this system in humans
parallel the effects of
tool making training.
The remaining question is
whether this is genetic
adaptation to tool making ability
or whether it's the developmental context
of growing up in a technological niche
or some combination of those two,
which is obviously the most likely thing.
Anyway, it's going to be complicated.
But, hopefully, by continued study
of the archeological record
and focused experimentation,
we can begin to sort out
some of these details
of the very extended
and multistage process
through which the modern human
technological niche evolved.
Thank you.
(applause)
(relaxing music)